over the course of the election campaign
we followed the efforts of three
candidates in three key seats three
women for whom personal victory or
defeat would likely reflect the national
fortunes of the parties they were
representing to achieve their electoral
aims the Liberal Democrats needed to win
wells in Somerset taken back Warsaw
north was key to Labour's hopes and the
conservative strategy rested on winning
places like Bishop Auckland for the very
first time
Tessa Mundt had been the MP for Wells
before hello just came to say hello my
name is Tessa yeah elected in 2010 she
lost her seat in 2015
failed to win it back in 2017 and this
time faced the challenge of overturning
a conservative majority of more than
7,000 she's been a well-known face here
in Glastonbury and there was welcomed
reception from some for her party's
pledge to revoke brexit and for goodness
sake yes I do want brakes it stopped yes
despite failing to win back the seat two
years ago she was hopeful and determined
to keep trying the best job in the world
and I really enjoyed doing it and I'm
very lucky because I suppose I had a
lifetime's ambition was to be an MP set
that for myself when I was seventeen
because I just thought that sounds like
a really interesting job and I've become
an MP so I've done that but having done
it I'm finished Merry Christmas
she was known here to on the edge of her
constituency is Burnham onsie a
predominantly conservative leave voting
area popular with retirees from
Birmingham in the Midlands when we
needed help this lady this lady it gets
my vote every time because she supports
people who need help this is not a seat
that needs an MP who doesn't care it
really isn't
it's a seat where people deserve to be
served properly by their MP being
justice
the people wrote if sufferer makes me
furious in the West Midlands geography
was also seeking to win people back also
North had been a Labour heartland for
decades but was lost in 2017 success
here would be critical to preventing
Boris Johnson from winning a
parliamentary majority the last time
around the Conservatives won by more
than two and a half thousand votes
there's a lot of people think that
politics isn't for them because they've
been disenfranchised you know they don't
see is an important part than I was but
it has an impact for generations to come
labor activists here knew how important
the fight was for the wider party's
prospects this is an area that voted to
leave but some of your councillors
you're out helping new campaign we're
telling me that there really needs the
impact of austerity and all cuts that is
something that they're seeing and
hearing tell me about that tell me about
how much of an issue it is here yeah
it's not just hearing it you actually
visibly see it as you're going out on
the streets you see in parents that are
struggling with their children I mean
we've got four to six percent poverty
rate of children within this one
constituency that's nearly wanting to
children that are going to school hungry
without proper clothing without heating
do you think this is quite an angry
election underneath you know you think
that there is a kind of a thread running
through it that is actually driven by
frustration and anger amongst the
electorate yeah there are there is
frustration there is there's not been so
much anger on the doorsteps and I some
of my colleagues have faced that but
I've not faced that anger here I think
that's because I fully understand I'm a
lever
I voted leave with them but for me it's
about the you know the dilly-dallying of
the Tory party for the
three years if winning back old ground
was Labor's challenge winning new ground
was the task for the Conservatives won
that DN a-- davidson took up for the
Tories in Bishop Auckland I'm sorry to
bother you my name is Deanna I'm
actually standing to your next MP so I'm
here today to ask if you've given any
thought to who you might be voting for
the seat had always been deep labour red
but a combination of the support for
brexit and the perceived dislike of
Jeremy Corbyn gave the Conservatives
hope it's cold but you know at the end
of the day I'm here fighting for every
single vote so I would be out rain or
shine whatever the weather talking to
people and because politics is about
people it's about trying to make
people's lives better a campaigning took
her through former mining villages
steeped in labour tradition decades ago
no one would ever afford that this seat
would turn conservative and yet here we
are with it as a top target we're
getting visits from government ministers
left right and centre getting activists
really wanting to come and help really
wanting to come and get engaged in this
campaign for all over the country
there's one thing I can say for Boris
Johnson is that he is a really
optimistic positive politician he has a
real vision for where he thinks our
country should go and that's the kind of
politics that I want to promote and sell
I'm not into nasty backbiting I'm not
into everything being an attack on the
opposition it has to be about what you
can do what you're going to deliver the
others victory invisible reflected the
change in the political climate that her
party's electoral strategy was
predicated on in mortal north of Wales
the opposite was true
despite their hopes and efforts neither
jill ography nor Tessa months were
ultimately able to swim against the
national tide it swept out against
labour and the Liberal Democrats
respectively and so for Deanna there is
now a place on the Commons green benches
today it's gonna sound really clever but
what I would love to be able to say that
I've done
in Parliament or in my career as a
politician if I can inspire one young
lass living on a council estate to cut
to kind of hold her head high and say
look someone's done that maybe I can do
it - then I will I will leave the very
happy woman but in five years time the
voters of Bishop Auckland Wales and
wattle North will head to the ballot box
again and as the last four general
elections have shown an awful lot can
change in this place and out in the
country between now and then Tom Rayner
Sky News Westminster